yeah you get one of these ones dude oh
man I'd rather be hit by the gloss side
than the Sandy side that's true that's
true would you rather be hit in the face
with a tile or shot in the ass
do you have roommates Taylor uh yeah
several roommates you get along yeah I
get along with them all they don't
always get along with each other
do you have to like kind of use the glue
what's the biggest beef that happens
yeah honestly the biggest it's nothing
much I think the biggest beef was when
the rent got risen like last year and
having to like renegotiate that some
people got really like wow you mean
negotiations yeah do you guys play like
trash Jenga too trash Jenga where like
no one wants to take it out so they just
find different ways of [__] stuff in
it yeah and it's like it should have
been taken out literally a week ago but
it's just [__] stuff to the bread it
becomes a fun game honestly I just kind
of took over all those responsibilities
and started I've been knowing my
roommates whenever I like got to a point
where I was like okay I've been doing
way more of the cleaning like just send
me money like if you're not gonna do it
just pay me for it hey that's a good
negotiation what if your roommate's like
no
didn't get there that's tight how much
you charge for taking off I wanted to
get a maid service and they didn't want
to do it so I was like the new clean and
then they said yeah I will clean it and
then they don't clean it's not the trash
that I was worried about it's more so
like vacuuming mopping like all of the
things that take like hours how much you
charge like they didn't even like want
to touch it yeah and like uh what's the
damage on there was a damage fifty
dollars per roommate for like whenever I
do like a daily deep cleaning session
deep clean yeah so how many other
roommates yet
that's just that's a sweet gig yeah that
is nice that's a sweet gig 150. you ever
try to export it and like do it every
single [__]
I mean it was definitely a kind of like
a risk making them pushing that on them
or whatever but at the same time it's
like get a business going on yeah
I do I pay you I think it's a good deal
I think that's a great deal like I try
to get them to mop and they were like
you do it like then they're like and
then they do a shitty job obviously did
it wrong to like try to get out of it
type energy oh that's what we do that's
what men do do you ever clear this I
don't know if they were actually playing
dumb or if they were actually just that
dumb they might be they might be have
you ever clashed with uh food storage in
the fridge or like somebody oh yeah
that's a big one some people want to buy
the whole actually the one who ends up
like eating something that belongs to
something
at least you own it how does that happen
though I always wonder because I'm like
you know you didn't buy this oh I mean
I'm high as [__] I'm hungry as [__] okay
okay and that looks good usually I'll
like show replace it that might be what
happened here there's a story that uh
this just occurred in Kentucky there's a
guy uh he's pretty old he's like in his
60s he's got a roommate and he's upset
at his roommate for eating the last Hot
Pocket
oh you don't [__] with a fight dude
fight yeah it's a big fight so what
happened they started arguing it
escalated uh and this is the literal
detail in the story is that they started
throwing Tiles at each other oh [__] and
then that escalated to being a child so
one guy that's not a Steve Green
original
it's not a Steve Green freestyle blank
screen
um so they start with three tiles how do
they have loose tiles just sitting
around Kentucky remodeling yeah yeah
yeah
one guy one guy who starts losing the
towel fight he tries to book it to the
door and then the other that dude takes
a gun out and shoots him in the ass oh
my God how do you know you're losing a
tile fight dude towels hurt bro switch
if you got a corner thrown at you you're
getting [__] up aren't they all
Corners well yeah
I prefer breaks off there's two
there's two we're like the sharp Corners
like turns soft Corner yeah you might
hear the edge but unless you have round
Terrazzo ones yeah you get one of these
ones dude oh man I'd rather be hit by
the gloss side than the Sandy side
that's true that's true would you rather
be hit in the face with a tile or shot
in the ass with a gun hit in the face
with a tongue yeah but what if you get a
scratch and your beautiful face is
scratched am I gonna die from the shot
you're not gonna die because that's
because that's kind of a cool story it
is it's gonna affect the squat Max
though yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm out of the gym for a little bit
here's another thing that makes this
story very very Kentucky and and not
California the um so the guy who got
shot he's fine he just went to hospital
got released they went together the
shooter
um didn't go to he just got released on
7 500 bail what and got charged with uh
assault yeah it sounds about right
that's kind of tight but not attempted
murder did the homie yeah is it because
the other homie was fighting too like
they were fighting each other it might
be yeah or he don't want to press Char
can you do that can you just be like I
don't want to press charges or something
yeah some some states I think like like
I think in Texas
um if you have beef with someone yeah
you can just throw down and it's called
a mutual whatever battle and then the
cops will be like oh God you guys want
to do that okay it's a mono imano so I
think in some states they view the
things differently it's not like a state
full of Hall monitors you know it's just
like man this is my [__] best friend
shot me in the ass yeah and then you're
like oh it's not a 10 murder you know
versus over here it's like
it's like elevated to uh you push it up
as much as you can because a lawyer's
gonna it's like a gym right you're right
you're right oh my God you gotta play
the victim well you know yeah I will say
from Missouri moving out here people are
like way more just like conscious about
here of like their legal rides you know
where they can get money you know you
think Californians are a little soft
soft yeah I think they're soft in
certain ways but harder in other ways oh
yeah I think they're harder more like
when a juice does come to higher levels
of intellectualism they fight different
here it's like yeah
I feel like they're more sophisticated
in paperwork fighting litigious yeah and
then like but they can't take a Punch
Yeah I mean they realize out here that
punches someone in the face doesn't hurt
as much as filing a lawsuit for half a
million dollars yeah because I feel like
at some states true like if your boss
ran over your foot or something wow it's
a [__] honest mistaker you know but
her like oh your boss ran over your foot
yeah it's a cha-ching move dude that's
like a quarter million yeah and then so
it's like it's just viewed differently
yeah yeah yeah that is true that's like
um that's like what happened to me when
I when I was uh getting my car from
valet and the some random guy just
smashed my door off
oh yeah and then they sued you well no
everybody around was like oh dude you're
gonna get
payday from that but like my reflex
wasn't to do that yeah and I didn't and
then why did you didn't do it you didn't
cash out no because I wasn't injured
you're a bad California I wasn't injured
but in order for me to cash out I would
have to first of all act injured go back
to Kentucky I would have to go to a lot
of appointments yeah and I would have to
I would have to be dedicated to the
faking I would have to be going to like
therapy and you guys are forgetting this
guy's worth 10 million dollars so why
the [__] well 18. exactly that's a waste
of your time yeah he doesn't need time
is money baby and what are you gonna do
like a innocent little family that needs
their [__] 100K or whatever you were
going to swim for I can't believe you
were thinking about some of them dude
that's [__] yeah yeah I do I do like
places that are are more like that like
you know in Taiwan
um the bumper is actually viewed as like
a bumper It's meant yeah it's meant to
be expected bumps it's like two cars
kind of scratch each other they just
come out and like ah whatever over here
it's like oh we've got the [__] 2003
Honda Prelude what'd you do that to me
and then it's like it's like they're
taking a wedding album of photos yeah a
wedding it's like it's gonna get
scratched anyways like it's part of your
car you're driving it 60 miles an hour
down the freeway like you don't think
there's gonna be Rock chips and you know
yeah like things are so magnified in
certain it's also the way that they
design modern cars too where they're
painted just as well as the rest of the
car well back in the day some bumpers
were wood or they were just straight up
a metal yeah it's a chrome or something
color than the rest of the [__] yeah
it's easier to fix and it's just you're
just meant to like oh you hit each other
bumpers now are pretty weak and it's got
soft dude we did we got completely dude
we did bumper curses kids till they
prepare ourselves for that and then
whenever you get to like use that skills
it's no fun when you can actually drive
yeah exactly gonna take a whiplash now
freaking false expectations they even
built cars in a way where like if you do
get a scratch if you get it back to the
dealership and it's going to be freaking
expensive or a body shop like I
scratched a little bit over my um Fender
right where it covers the wheel a little
bit and then they're like that's gonna
cost like 300 and I'm like hey trying to
[__] with me so I go to another store
they're like yeah it's gonna cost around
like three to four hundred and I'm like
why and he goes you see this texture
right there he goes they built it like
this where it's not like a smooth gloss
finish like this so then if you want to
match that it's much harder to do and
they're like it's planned out and I'm
like what because they know that area
gets scratched a lot but can I tell you
the situation I was in that I got stuck
in the middle I really couldn't do
anything about it I was at Starbucks in
the car editing JK [__] and
um there's no one parked to my right or
left some girl parts really close to me
on this side and she didn't have to
because there's no one else parked there
you're in the parking lot or drive I'm
just sitting in the in the car and
parking lot and she goes so close to my
door she's a bigger woman she opens the
door super fast and it just hits my
mirror and takes a little chunk off and
she looks at and goes and she just like
gets out and walks away what a jerk and
I normally my reflexes say something but
she was so big that I felt like it would
look like a hate crime if I was young
you would get in trouble for yelling so
I didn't
I didn't know what to do I was like I'm
in a situation where if I get mad I look
like yeah a piece of [__] she's probably
gonna go well you know I didn't have any
space
but but no matter what it's not an
awesome plate and take a picture of the
damage and just like send her a bill
yeah I didn't want to do anything I was
just kind of like imagine being so fat
that you can't even [__] Park away
from someone you got to crowd everybody
at no matter what but why did she closer
she's fat
you look like the type like she had
like
teal colored hair the scowl you know
those she did have to like generally I
got it
a Facebook activist she just looked she
looked angry she looked pretty angry
because you know what though because
those are the people that might pull out
their phone that's what I'm saying oh
you're so oh this guy assaulted me yeah
I'm alive right now he's assaulting he
didn't I didn't want it to be a
situation where she says well he I was
here first and then like she's recording
like who knows yeah who knows what kind
of you're a dancer you could have just
danced
do a tick tock dance
[Music]
foreign